hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 2019 Isle of Man
chess tournament a lot of you have
requested it and again for very good
reasons
so thank you for that it's fish
monitamon vs. vladimir pharaoh save and
the ledges dive straight into it and
also i hope you are having an excellent
weekend so with the white pieces Anand
opens with E for now we have C 5 by
Pharaoh save the Sicilian defence with
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and d4 so just
going for rapid development we have C
captures Knight captures and the Queen
to b6 now asking do you want to go for
some Bishop to e3 Queen captures and b2
ideas or do you want to continue the
game in a different fashion
we have night stir b3 not allowing the
trade on and prefers to keep the pieces
on the board and also now the bishop can
be developed with ecigs by black
preparing to develop the dark square
Bishop also d5 might be an idea in the
future and nice the c3 Anand continues
development we have Queen to c7 the
bishop is coming to e3 at some point so
you don't want your Queen and b6 and
also it prevents the bishop from being
developed to the much more active f4
square with f4 by Anand now and d6 and
here we have Bishop to e3 the there is a
game where Queen Torito was played but
Bishop to e3 is and you move in the
position and it is already as a move 8/8
that we have a completely new game and
well I very often when we have a
completely new game from such an early
stage in the game you know things tend
to get a bit crazy so let's see if this
is one such game we have Knight to f6
fear of fair safe continuous development
with Bishop to d3 also just developing a
piece defending d4 pawn and the Bishop
to e7 preparing the Castle kingside
whereas on and ghost Queen to f3 and
leaves the option of casting both Queen
side and Kings side with Knights to be
for now Pharaoh Civ plays with the night
one more time in the opening he wants to
grab the lights for a bishop here and
eliminate honor the bishop pair with
castles by Anand Anand goes for the King
side castle and now Bishop to d7 and
here a3 on and says okay I'm gonna give
up the bishop pair I'm gonna improve my
pawn structure
Center and also I'm getting the the open
file for my rook with Knight captures on
d3 we have C capture son d3 and now
comes Queen to c6 with the idea that
after the route comes to c1 you want to
transfer your Queen over to the asic
square which will sort of not waste time
as the d3 point is not defended so rook
a to c1 just continue in development or
a very nice word for the rook and the
Queen to a6 and here aren't says your
king is still in the center of the board
your pieces aren't really a coordinated
adjust yet your bishop pair still in the
seventh rank and I don't think you will
go after this d3 point so here Anand
goes g4 he prepares g5 and he is correct
to do so if for example if Queen
captures on d3 yes you do grab a pawn
but rook F to D one pushes the Queen
back and after Queen to A six now g5
comes and after the knight moves
somewhere let's say Knight to g8 f5 and
the White will get a deadly attack for
this d3 pawn and black just cannot
afford such such a powerful attack so
after g4 we have Bishop to c6 now
getting the bishop to this much better
diagonal also preventing e5 now has the
D pawn is pinned and g5 now by Anand
pushing the knight back with Knight to
d7 and now d4 so the d3 pawn no longer a
target and you have d5 prepared in some
lines so Bishop to b5 not allowing d5 to
come with an attack on the bishop also
you are now attacking the rook on f1
rook to f2 and just get that out of the
way and only now that's Pharaoh safe
castle and Anand it doesn't feel like
waiting any longer the rook is still on
8/8 the Queen is oddly placed on a6 the
bishop on b5 attacking who knows what so
here Anand continues the attack on the
Kings side with f5 and here Bishop to d8
you don't want to allow f6 to come with
an attack on the bishop this way after
Bishop 38 now Anand could play f6 but
after g6 okay you have Queen to h3 you
could go for this mating idea but then
black can play h5 and after it captures
ample Sun King takes on create a
blockade using using Conlon's pawns and
would still be much better here but
Anand finds a different
he says I can always push f6 there is no
rush first I want to maximize the
activity of my pieces night study - now
Anand is preparing at some point to pull
this pawn to e5 and to cut created the
e4 square for for the night with Bishop
to d3 now if the five point is pushed
then there also will be a double attack
on the f5 pawn so here under has a
couple of ways he could deal with the
Bishop to d3 move he could go nice to a2
followed by nice to be for with a double
attack on the Queen and the bishop also
Queen to h3 is an idea just getting the
Queen out of the way and I'm preparing
f6 once again but Anand chooses a
different more forcing light he captures
on f6 with F captures on e6 and the now
comes Queen to g4 with threatening Queen
capture son Ani sex with check feather
Saif captures on e on f2 now you cannot
capture first with check because then
black just brings the rook back rook to
have 7 blocks so you would you know
loser loser rook there so we have King
captures I have to first and now tonight
back to f8 and defending the e6 pawn and
now d5 here on and says ok I'm attacking
your east exponent Weiss also I want to
get to this diagonal for my bishops off
yourself of course prevents both ideas
would be 5 and here on unjust continues
with h4 we have g6 here kind of
preventing h5 but not really on and
still pushes it with h5g captures Queen
captures and now Bishop to b6 here with
ideas of just trading off at the dark
square Bishop and if the Queen ever
moves from from this diagonal then also
ideas like Bishop to e2 come to mind if
you can somehow bring the bishop over to
help out with the defense of the King
said it would be great for Farah safe
with king queen to h3 for Anand now or
keeping an eye on the bishop on e3 and
also if the knight moves you also have
some Queen to e6 ideas so we have looked
8 now preventing that and the knight the
d1 now adding another defender to the
bishop and also now you have to be very
careful if the rook moves for example
from from the back rank rook the C it
could be an idea so definitely an
excellent file for the rook with Bishop
to e2 now putting pressure on that I
hear but also just preparing Bishop
captures here and then King will not be
very likely to capture so after Queen
captures the idea is just Bishop back to
h5 to g6 so if you could get this Bishop
to g6 it would be a very nice defending
piece so King t1 here on undone pin so
now the bishop can also move and Bishop
to d4 now just keeping you know keeping
the tension and Anand continues to bring
his pieces into more active squares
Knight 2 f2 and here the best idea for
Pharaoh service just Bishop characters
on e3 Queen captures on e3 and Bishop
back to h5 where you will not have
options of continuing the attack for
example you have to be very careful if
Queen h3 you go after the Bishop just
Queen to e2 is checkmate
so here black would also get some
counter play and Anand would have to
figure out a way how to continue here
but photocell first decided to play rook
to e7 to bring yet another defender over
to the to the King side also to prevent
rook to c7 he thought maybe rook to c7
was a bigger threat than rook to e7 but
it's actually not so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the best
plan for Anand in this situation while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such an
active nice plant for almond and for
those of you who just want to enjoy so
yes rook the rook to see it is a very
nice move but Anand chooses the more
forcing Bishop captures on d4 with each
captures and only now rook the c8 and
roof to see it comes with a very deadly
threat for example if if ever save
continues with something like d3 or
plays a slow move then Anand has the
plan of not Queen a f5 fall by captures
on F n because you can block that with
rook to f7 the real threat for Anand
here is Queen to e6 check and this is
just just a wild idea of course the
knight cannot capture because it's
pinned and after the rook captures you
get D captures on e6 and there's no
defense against East 7 rather there is
you cannot go
you have to go to g7 but then still East
7 and now night has to move or you don't
move the night and then the pawn capture
it for example 96 and then you just
bring your Queen to the game and again
there's not much you can do here with
black if an IG 5 check Queen f8 check
and you are in trouble
King in g6 Queen to f5 check King will
go to h6 and now just look to g8 there
isn't there really is nothing you can do
here whatever you try 93 it is an
attempt but just Knight captures and you
don't even have Queen to a5 check
because the Queen covers the a5 square
so a rope to c8 with with the deadly
idea of Quinta east sex but Pharaoh self
prevents it we have worked the f8 now
Quinte sex will not be all that
impressive but Anand continues the
attack with E 5 so what do you do here
of course you don't want to allow East 6
so Pharaoh self captures once and now
night after efore the e4 square has been
cleared for Anand night so again the
best for Pharaoh save is Queen to d3
this is the last chance for him and if
Queen captures Bishop captures you have
to allow Knight to f6 check where you
pretty much have to give up the exchange
if you don't if you play King g7 then
then this night is coming to f3 to a 5
and then the 2 nights will be will be
really deadly
so Queen to d3 the best for Pharaoh save
he decided to play h5 and then on just
captured the G captures on h6 and here
we have rook to f4 and again I would I
would ask you to pause the video and I
will in fact I will so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
way to end this game for 400 while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to -
congratulations on finding the nicest
possible way to end the game for Anand
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show a lot of moves are
winning here if you found h7
that means if you found Luke captures
rook captures and f8 that also wins if
you found the d6 just preventing the
Queen from getting into the game that is
also very nice so I will show this rook
captures Anna fate as it is just a
brute-force line rook captures an f8 and
now Queen to g2 with this you are able
to infiltrate King
seven and now Queen to g7 sharp kink the
eight and now d6 again not allowing the
Queen to help out with the defense
that's right ace Queen e7 mate
there is nothing to do here rook f7 you
can block but then just Knight f6 check
you cannot capture because of Queenie
seven mates we have to move the King and
now the pawn and the knight control all
the squares in front of the black King
so now it's pretty straightforward check
block and this is made but Anand went
for a much more stylish idea he didn't
go for a brute force long he played the
much nicer Quinta a6 check and it was in
this position unmoved 37 that Vladimir
first resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here if you
accept the the Queen trade Queen
captures pawn captures it's a similar
idea there's no defense against East 7
again rather there is you have to move
the King and then after each seven comes
you will either allow a dis capture or
you will get a Queen enter game so it's
better to prevent the queening and then
you just get he captures on f8 bring the
Queen enter game rook captures rook
captures and you are not up just a whole
rug but also a piece and the rook so of
course completely winning and after
Queen to e6 check if you don't want to
trade Queens you don't really have any
other good options you could block rook
to f7 but then just Knight f6 check King
the h8 and now just Queen captures on f7
and there is no defense against Queen to
g7 mate there there is no even a there's
no way to even make the game last longer
so after Queen to e6 checked first I
resigned in the excellent victory for
Charlotte and Ireland which also brings
him I believe to at the five and a half
points so regarding the standings I will
always put a link in the description
below with the standings just 24 where
you can just scroll through all of the
results but I will mention that the
current leaders with six points are
Fabiana corona Antonov Uehara and xi
Oregon so three of them with six points
Aggie Hara will face arena in the next
round and Caruana faces none other than
Magnus Carlsen so we will have a in
today's game and Magnus versus karana
world number one versus world number two
so definitely
be very exciting or not we'll just have
to wait and see what we see some
leftovers of the World Chess
Championship preparation or maybe
something completely different and with
five and a half points following the
leaders are wrong how key relaxing apart
from box to loop a virus love Kovalev
Magnus cross and Nikita with you go
safely hurricane kick or Nakamura
Vishwanathan Anand and Boris Gelfand so
anyone still has an opportunity and
three more games to go if on the wins
all three games that follow we might see
Anand in the next candidates tournament
which will be completely crazy but you
know it's just anything can happen
yeah now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Simon
Richardson Richard Yarnell and crispy
card for a contribution to my channel I
think you lot I really appreciate it
sorry I forgot Thomas Vivian and David
autumn are also you gentlemen as well I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I'm
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon continue in the coverage of the of
the isle of man chess tournament I've
continued to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and well of course
everything else that happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend